i see this post this is one to tell you
that you pulled up earlier that said
this is a teacher
it says teachers claim entire class of
second grade students change their
pronouns
and it's being kept a secret from unsafe
that's in quotation marks that's her
quotation mark i don't know how she
identifies adults
all right so let's try let's give it a
shot to play this video we have a little
tech issue here today so be patient with
us but we're going to try to play this
video and see what happens
i'm going to make this tick tock um
without crying because
that's what i do um please ignore the
dog bone crunching behind me anyhow um
one of my students felt safe enough to
share his pronouns with me
and
when he did so
once the class knew that i knew they all
switched pronouns
they're second graders
like i'm torn between being really
really happy to be a safe space
and just absolutely furious that an
entire group of second graders has to
keep this secret from not safe okay
let's pause this for a second
so
what horrifies me about it is that she
doesn't understand what a second grader
is
you understand how this story played out
this is a teacher to second graders
second graders are seven eight years old
you know a seven or eight year old in
your life you got a kid that's seven or
eight you had a kid seven or eight you
teach a kid that's seven or eight nieces
and nephews seven or eight you've met a
seven or eight year old
okay so essentially what happens here is
that
one student shares
you know his or her pronouns with the
teacher
all the kids find out and then all the
kids start saying that like oh
what's what's her name said she's a boy
i'm a boy i'm a boy i'm a boy too i'm a
can you just see how this second grade
see how this could go i mean my kid sits
in front of me i'm not kidding we read
curious george and i'm like
i read a line like where's my little
monkey i'm a monkey he says he wants to
be a monkey he loves george
he what that's he's a child he's two and
a half granted he's not seven or eight
think about a seven or eight year old so
it she hasn't grasped
that maybe this is just about kids not
really understanding the depth of this
concept
and they're just like i'm a boy i'm a
girl i'm a boy i'm a like they don't
really get it right they're like oh
somebody just read me a story about a
boy who explains maybe i'm a boy okay
i'm a boy call me a boy
okay she's assuming that there's a depth
of understanding
that cannot happen that cannot be
processed in seven or eight eighth grade
eight-year-old i'm sorry mind or 8th or
7th or 8th grade for that matter in many
capacities if you've if you've dealt
with 7th or 8th graders
separate conversation but these are
second graders which is even more
ridiculous
okay let's just finish the rest of the
video please natalia when you get a
second
why are kids feeling unsafe
and
furthermore why does everyone talk about
how how are the kids going to understand
kids [ __ ] understand it
it's easy for them it's the adults who
have all of the freaking issues and
hang ups and [ __ ] kids are fine it's
clearly it's clearly
the children
that understand this issue in great
capacity she immediately assumed that
these kids felt unsafe
like well they were withholding this
information second grade
i keep saying it because you need to
understand second grade we're not
talking about high schoolers here it's a
very different conversation you're
talking about high schoolers you're
talking about second graders here the
assumption was that these
second graders had such a complexity of
mind
that they said we feel unsafe let me
withhold this information oh that
student shared it so now and the whole
class just starts changing their pro
that doesn't seem odd to you
that the whole class just kind of chimed
in and was just like oh yeah i'm gonna
change my product
you people aren't allowed to talk about
the social component of this
right because it goes against woke
ideology you're supposed to just accept
that even though all of this woke stuff
is being shoved down kids throats in
school 24 hours a day
you're supposed to accept that it's not
odd that you have so many more kids now
coming out and saying well i'm not a boy
i'm a girl i'm not of this at very very
young ages and that there can't possibly
be a correlation between them being
flooded with this stuff
all day long
and the fact that their little minds
just say oh maybe i'm this or maybe i'm
that and can't process this at the level
that an adult can isn't it something
like your brain's not fully formed
natalie check this for me i think it's
like your brain's not at full
adult capacity till it's like until
you're like 25.
i think it's 25.
these are impressionable little
second graders okay
where is the adult in the room
where is the adult in the room is she
supposed to be it
god help us
seriously god help us is it 25 i think
it's 25 or 20. yeah it's 25 until the
age of 25 okay
second grade y'all
okay
so again
this this needs to be discussed in a
different way because there's people in
society that are treating these little
kids like adults and you've got puberty
blockers coming into play now you've got
gender surgeries coming into play you've
got medications coming into play you've
got stuff that
some they say oh everything's reversible
well there's a lot of doctors that say
maybe it's not all reversible or what
are the implications you got a lot of
parents asking questions but you've got
a lot of stuff coming into play here
that's quite serious it's not just i
identify as a different gender end of
story there's stuff coming into play
that's actually altering
the physicality
the hormones of children in order in
order to support what a very small child
might say one day and not even
understand
okay so we need to be willing and able
to have this conversation that this is
not
this is not functional adult commentary
on this if you're talking about second
graders and saying of course they can
understand everything it's the adults
that are well you're part of the problem
if you like the short clip you can catch
another one here or you can catch the
full episode right here
[Music]